Le Café de
l’Espace des sciences, avec la revue
Science Ouest,
Bonsoir !
Bonsoir à toutes et à tous.
Merci d'être là, autour de nous,
si nombreux.
Bienvenue au Café de l'Espace
des sciences sur l'homme augmenté ce soir.
Cette rencontre est organisée par l'équipe
de rédaction du magazine Science Ouest.
Qui peut être ?
Peut être que vous ne le connaissez
ou peut être pas.
C'est
un magazine de vulgarisation scientifique
qui est édité par l'Espace des sciences
mensuel, qui présente et décortique
l'actualité scientifique de la région.
Si vous ne le connaissez pas,
n'hésitez pas à aller le découvrir
vers mon collègue
tout à l'heure en partant.
Nous avions notamment publié
il y a quelques mois
un dossier sur l'homme augmenté.
C'est pour cela que nous sommes là
ce soir pour aller un peu plus loin
ou pour
revenir sur certains aspects de ce sujet
que nous avions traité dans ce dossier.
Donc pendant cette rencontre, n'hésitez
pas à poser vos questions.
Vous êtes invités à participer
à l'échange, bien évidemment.
Pour cela, je vous invite à lever la main
pour que mon collègue puisse
vous donner un micro.
Est ce que l'événement est enregistré ?
Et c'est beaucoup plus facile
pour nous entendre les uns et les autres ?
Mais n'hésitez pas à nous faire signer.
On vous vous donnera la parole.
Alors ce soir, j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir
deux invités pour parler de ce vaste
sujet.
François Lhote, vous êtes philosophe
à l'université de Rennes.
Et puis Gérard de Bois Boissel,
vous êtes ingénieur de recherche
au Crec, au centre de recherche
des écoles de Saint-Cyr Coëtquidan.
J'ai bien prononcé.
C'est un fait. Merci. Bonjour à tous.
Et vous allez pouvoir notamment
nous parler du soldat augmenté.
Il y a pas mal de
choses à dire sur ce sujet.
Nous vous avions
interviewé, ont tous les deux
pour ce dossier.
Donc, comme je le disais,
l'idée de ce soir, c'est de revenir
sur certains aspects. Donc n'hésitez pas
à répondre ou à enrichir ou à rebondir
par rapport aux questions du public.
Je crois que c'est un sujet qui flirte
pas mal avec la fiction,
donc on va pouvoir vraiment faire
les contours de ces sujets de long
et en large.
Alors peut être qu'on peut commencer
justement par une définition
de l'homme
augmenté l'homme avec un grand H.
Est ce que l'on peut dire qu'augmenter
l'être humain, c'est de mobiliser
les sciences et les technologies
pour augmenter ses capacités ?
Peut être qu'il y a des désaccords.
Je ne sais pas s'il y a un consensus,
mais comment vous,
vous vous définissez
cette expression homme augmenté ?
Bonsoir à tous.
Cette expression d'homme augmenté,
elle a une origine relativement récente
finalement.
Et le but, le but est vraiment d'augmenter
ses capacités, ses capacités physiques,
ses capacités cognitives,
mais de les augmenter
jusqu'à l'infini.
Si on pense au transhumanisme,
il s'agit d'augmenter ces capacités
à l'infini et donc ça pose immédiatement.
Autant la poser directement.
Cette question philosophique
est ce que l'homme
est ce que l'autre est
ce que l'être humain est un être qui peut
s'augmenter, s'augmenter, s'augmenter
ou est ce qu'il est limité ?
Et à partir de là, on a déjà une sorte
de réflexion sur cette augmentation
puisque moi je suis le philosophe,
Donc je pose les questions conceptuelles
et donc voilà donc l'augmentation,
l'augmentation.
Il y a le solde augmenté, mais il y a
toutes les augmentations possibles,
à la fois physiques, cognitives,
en gros en fait l'augmentation du corps,
l'augmentation de l'esprit
et avec l'aide de la technologie
bien sûr, et une technologie
qui va s'inviter et qui va se rapprocher
de nous presque jusqu'à l'infini.
Et avec cette tendance
que nous avons à l'accepter
parce qu'elle nous rend des services,
elle répond à nos désirs
et transforme nos problèmes
aux problèmes techniques.
La technique transforme ça
en cahier des charges et nous voilà
pris finalement dans le train
de la technique.
Voilà.
D'un point de vue philosophique, ce qu'est
l'augmentation
et tous les problèmes que cela peut poser.
Mais peut être que d'un autre point de vue
beaucoup plus concret sans doute,
Qu'est ce que l'augmentation ?
Alors ? Bonsoir à tous.
Donc la déclinaison que je vais vous
proposer est spécifiquement militaire.
Donc c'est un prisme assez particulier.
L'idée pour le monde militaire,
c'est d'être plus efficient
en opérations militaires,
c'est à dire qu'il y a une finalité
qui est l'efficacité opérationnelle
pour conserver une supériorité
sur l'adversaire afin de afin de vaincre.
Alors, dans la définition
des effectivement, vous avez parlé
d'augmenter ses capacités
ou pourquoi pas d'acquérir des capacités ?
Oui, tout à fait.
Ça fait partie de la définition.
Je vais juste citer une acquisition
de capacité, c'est voir la nuit.
L'être humain ne voit pas la nuit,
certains animaux font des panneaux,
donc c'est être nyctalope.
Eh bien si un militaire on lui donne
cette capacité de pouvoir voir la nuit,
alors il est augmenté.
Il a un avantage sur son adversaire
et il va pouvoir être
plus efficace en opérations.
Ça rejoint
aussi
la notion de dépassement de ces limites.
Je dirais pas à l'infini,
parce que je ne crois pas à l'infini
pour les capacités humaines,
mais en tout cas aller plus loin,
plus loin que ces limites, alors qu'elles
sont telles dans le monde militaire.
Eh bien, il y a des invariants qui sont
des limites physiologiques, humaines.
C'est le sommeil par exemple,
on est tous sujets au sommeil.
Et si dans le monde militaire
vous dormez et que l'ennemi ne dort pas,
et bien vous vous perdez.
Et quand je dis perdez, c'est dramatique,
vous perdez la vie.
Donc c'est repousser ses limites
qui sont des limites.
Alors je le dis physiologique,
mais c'est les limites du corps.
Voilà, c'est aller
aller plus vite,
plus loin, durer plus longtemps.
Mais c'est aussi des limites, comme ça
a été indiqué à l'instant.
Les limites cognitives, c'est pouvoir
peut être être aidé dans sa réflexion
et porter plus loin
une réflexion avec une aide extérieure
éventuellement.
Alors on parlera des moyens après.
Mais je pense qu'on
va pouvoir aller où je peux vous dire.
Est ce que c'est un courant assez récent
finalement ?
Vous parliez des transhumanistes
tout à l'heure.
Peut être que vous pouvez un petit peu
nous en parler
et on pense notamment à l'essor
des technologies.
Est ce qu'on en parle beaucoup aujourd'hui
de l'homme augmenté ?
Mais est ce que finalement, il n'y a pas
toujours eu une certaine augmentation
de l'être humain et surtout une envie
peut être de l'augmenter ?
Oui, alors en ce qui concerne la notion
d'augmentation, elle ne date pas d'hier,
même si elle était reprise effectivement
par les nouvelles technologies.
Le fait que les technologies
se concentrent
et proposent des solutions inimaginables
autrefois,
elle a toujours été dans la tête
des hommes, même déjà à la Renaissance.
Au Pic de la Mirandole par exemple,
disait que Dieu
avait créé l'homme, mais que l'homme bien,
il devait finir la création.
Donc il avait
un job à faire, de continuer.
Mais jusqu'où ?
Même les Lumières
ou les Lumières pensaient par exemple
qu'on pouvait s'améliorer.
Très, très, très longtemps.
On pensait pas vraiment à l'immortalité,
mais quand même très loin.
Plus près de nous, Claude
Bernard, au XIXᵉ siècle, parle par exemple
d'être l'ingénieur de l'évolution.
Vous savez, l'évolution darwinienne,
c'est bien,
mais c'est lent et c'est du bricolage.
Et donc contre ce bricolage
de l'évolution darwinienne, une évolution
d'ingénierie sur nos propres organismes
permet d'avancer.
Mais vraiment ça s'est stabilisé.
Et le terme transhumanisme ?
Il vient vraiment de Julien Clerc
et le frère d'Aldous Huxley.
Et ce personnage,
qui était un biologiste eugéniste
mais pas un eugéniste du genre
qui fait peur comme l'eugénisme nazi,
mais un eugénisme vraiment où On pensait
qu'il fallait améliorer,
améliorer finalement
nos faiblesses biologiques.
Il fallait les améliorer
et un eugénisme relativement libéral,
voire social était défendu.
Et il a introduit le terme transhumanisme.
Mais vraiment,
le transhumanisme est porté aujourd'hui
par les entreprises à la fois chinoises,
mais surtout celles que l'on connaît plus
les entreprises
de la côte de la côte américaine
où tout se fait,
à savoir les GAFA, et cetera Et donc,
chez Google par exemple, on a une sorte
de prophète du transhumanisme
qui est l'ingénieur en chef
qui est Raymond Kurzweil
et qui est vraiment comme celui
qui nous prédit, qui nous prédit
une disparition progressive du corps ?
Oui, tout de suite.
Vous parliez du
du corps qui avait sans doute des limites
et on pouvait voir la nuit.
Mais en fait, quel est l'adversaire
pour le transhumanisme ?
Bien l'adversaire, c'est notre biologie.
La biologie peut être si imparfaite
et parfois on a envie de rien faire.
Vous avez parlé d'efficacité ?
Oui. Le mot efficacité
est un mot, vraiment de la technologie.
Nous n'avons pas
à être forcément efficaces
et donc il y a, il y a chez nous,
avec nos faiblesses biologiques,
quelque chose qu'on aimerait modifier.
Et donc le transhumanisme
porté par ces entreprises.
Les datas, les entreprises de Google,
les entreprises autour de toutes ces
ces nouvelles technologies
nous promettent vraiment l'immortalité.
Il y a d'ailleurs
un médecin un peu un peu moins qualifié.
Il s'appelle Alexandre, je ne sais plus.
Son prénom, Laurent. Laurent ? Alexandre ?
Presque le représentant du transhumanisme
à la française.
A mon avis, il dit qu'un enfant, un enfant
qui vivra 1000 ans et des jeunes des.
Et donc ici on a vraiment.
On nous propose
une immortalité technologique.
Attention, ce n'est pas une immortalité.
Comme elle n'était pas
comme elle était portée par la religion,
c'est une immortalité immanente
et non transcendante.
Et donc c'est quand même dans le projet.
Et Raymond Kurzweil est quand même
un ingénieur ingénieur en chef chez Google
en parle comme cela.
Alors c'est de la science fiction ?
Pour l'instant, c'est sûr,
Mais ça ouvre une perspective.
Parce que dès que dès qu'on considère
que notre biologie n'est pas suffisante
pour faire les choses jusqu'où,
on doit s'hybrider avec les machines.
C'est là que vous avez
sans doute vos limites, j'imagine.
Dans le domaine militaire
de l'hybridation en tout cas,
on ne peut pas parler de l'hybridation.
Alors je vous laisse rebondir.
Alors
oui, il y a quand même
dans le transhumanisme
une sorte de dépréciation de l'homme.
C'est à dire ?
Pour se transcender,
il faut abolir son corps
parce que c'est l'ennemi.
Ça, dans le monde militaire, non,
parce que on fait la guerre
avec son corps.
Et puis peut être que dans la société,
on vit aussi avec notre corps,
je le précise.
Alors votre question était est
ce que c'est nouveau dans votre milieu ?
Ou alors depuis l'aube de l'humanité ?
Malheureusement, il y a des conflits.
Ça commence avec Caïn et Abel
dans l'histoire, évidemment biblique.
Mais l'homme, depuis longtemps
malheureusement,
se crée des factions et combat
l'un et l'autre.
Donc chercher à s'augmenter,
c'est depuis depuis que la guerre existe,
Alors on a plusieurs façons
de s'augmenter avec un armement plus fort
que celui de votre adversaire,
votre adversaire,
un arc qui tire plus loin.
Mais il y a d'autres méthodes.
Il y a des et des substances
qui ont été utilisées dans.
Dans l'histoire,
on peut citer la secte des assassins
qui, lorsque les croisés l'ont rencontrée
au XIᵉ siècle, au XIIᵉ siècle,
ont été assez sidérés du du pouvoir que
le haschich avait sur ces combattants.
Donc ils étaient quelque part
très efficients dans le monde militaire
parce qu'ils prenaient cette substance,
mais ils perdaient toute lucidité.
Ça se retrouve aujourd'hui
dans une substance qui est utilisée
beaucoup par les djihadistes,
qui s'appelle le Captagon.
C'est une substance
qui fait que vous êtes très focalisé
sur votre objectif,
mais vous perdez toute empathie.
Donc le Captagon
vous fonçait vers l'ennemi.
Mais s'il y a un enfant, passe devant vous
le tuer, alors vous comprenez bien que
voilà ça,
ça arrive encore de nos jours
dans l'histoire militaire.
Mais l'armée française
ne veut absolument pas entendre
parler de ça
parce que le libre arbitre est atteint.
Donc il y avait des substances.
Il y a aussi les bersac ou Berserker
dans l'histoire des Vikings qui prenaient
des champignons hallucinogènes
et qui devenaient fous furieux au combat
et ressentaient la douleur.
Et c'était un peu le Panzer de l'époque
qui fonçait
à travers les lignes ennemies
et qui faisait des ravages épouvantables.
Voilà donc donc dans l'histoire
tout ce qui est substance.
Mais il y a aussi
des valeurs de dépassement qui sont
des valeurs, par exemple patriotiques
ou ou religieuses,
ce qui vous donne une force morale
et avec une force morale,
vous êtes capable de vaincre un ennemi,
même si sur le papier,
vous n'êtes pas forcément plus fort
que lui,
en nombre, en équipement, et cetera
parce que votre force morale
est supérieure.
C'est aussi
une façon de quelque part de s'augmenter
dépassement par des valeurs.
Et je vous laisse dire là
c'est intéressant.
Ça m'amène une question parce que
vous parlez de différents objectifs.
Finalement, je pense au but médical.
On sait qu'il y a certaines personnes,
notamment en situation de handicap,
qui pourraient
avoir besoin de s'augmenter.
Je pense que le terme là
est très discutable,
Je pense par exemple aux prothèses.
C'est aussi ça peut être nécessaire.
Finalement, au delà d'avoir une envie
d'être un super héros, un super soldat.
Je caricature, mais voilà.
Est ce que on parle
d'homme réparé, d'homme augmenté ?
Est ce qu'il
y a une frontière entre les deux ?
Quelle est elle ?
Est ce qu'elle est si fine
que ça se comprend ?
La question concernant la santé,
elle concerne le concept de santé.
Quand nous
disons retrouver la santé,
être en bonne santé,
se souhaiter une bonne année
en bonne santé à ce moment là.
Le concept de santé, c'est un concept
de santé comme fin en soi, c'est dire.
J'étais malade, j'ai attrapé une angine,
j'avais des bactéries,
on m'a donné un antibiotique,
je n'ai plus de bactéries,
je retrouve mon état normal
et la santé est ici une fin en soi.
Mais il y a une autre acception au mot
santé
qu'est la santé, comme ressources,
comme moyen pour une fin.
Et à ce moment là, la santé n'est plus,
n'est plus une plus comme objectif
d'être une fin en soi,
mais d'être un moyen pour quelque chose.
Et à partir du moment où on met en avant
ce deuxième aspect
du concept de santé, à savoir
le concept de santé comme ressource,
à ce moment là,
on peut, on peut aller chez le médecin
pour autre chose que le retour à l'état
normal de son organisme
et pour, par exemple, bien à ce moment
là, augmenter, se réparer et la différence
entre se réparer
et s'améliorer est complètement cassé.
Parce que ici, le but c'est de d'utiliser
la santé
comme étant un moyen pour une fin.
Et donc ici, on voit bien
qu'on a deux façons de considérer la santé
et dans le dans le soldat augmentée
ou dans le transhumanisme,
c'est vraiment la santé comme ressource
et à ce moment là, ça ne s'arrête plus.
On peut imaginer,
on peut
imaginer tout ce qu'on veut
pour nous reproduire, pour nous,
pour nous recharger
d'une façon ou d'une autre.
Alors évidemment, ça commence toujours
par quelque chose de médical.
On peut penser par exemple
aux exosquelettes qui sont
qui sont certainement utilisés, j'imagine,
dans le cadre du développement
du soldat augmenté.
Alors ça permet
à une personne handicapée de marcher,
ce qui est vraiment formidable.
Et mais il y a toujours comme ça
une première perspective
qui est une perspective de santé
que nous allons accepter.
Comment ne pas accepter quelque chose
comme ça ?
Et puis, une fois, une fois que
une fois que la perspective de santé
est acceptée, à ce moment là,
on peut aller au delà, au delà, au delà.
Je pense par exemple à Elon Musk
qui, qui fait tellement de choses
et qui est par exemple
le fondateur d'une société
qui s'appelle Neural Link
et qu'il ne s'agit pas de s'hybrider
complètement, mais d'équiper,
d'équiper avec des neurones artificiels
nos cerveaux afin de rivaliser,
par exemple avec les IA,
les intelligences artificielles
et donc ici, on a une certaine idée.
On a une certaine idée de ce que peut être
la technologie à la fois.
Elle pourrait réparer effectivement
nous réparer sur certaines maladies,
mais on voit bien que ça commence toujours
par quelque chose
que nous allons accepter
et qui va modifier petit à petit
la question qu'on peut se poser
est ce qu'on doit rivaliser
avec les intelligences artificielles ?
Ça, c'est vraiment une grosse question.
Où est ce qu'on doit considérer
que les intelligences artificielles
sont à notre service
et qu'il n'y a pas de.
Il n'y a pas vraiment.
Ce sont des outils et
ça ne doit pas être plus que des outils.
Mais si on pense qu'elles vont rivaliser,
est ce qu'il
faut qu'on se mette à la hauteur ?
Vous voyez qu'à chaque fois,
il y a quelque chose de très acceptable.
Et à partir du moment où on a
le concept de santé comme ressources,
c'est vraiment la porte ouverte.
Si vous voulez, on ne sait pas jusqu'où.
Voilà un peu de concept de santé,
vraiment.
C'est assez important que la bonne santé.
Retour à soi même, à l'organisme normal.
Georges Canguilhem qui en parlait comme ça
et la santé comme ressource,
c'est à dire à ce moment là, est bien où
On n'a plus vraiment de limite
où on peut vraiment faire
tout ce qu'on veut
puisque le but n'est pas de retrouver
l'état normal de son organisme.
On est au delà.
Ça va, ça va de l'esthétique.
Il y a toute une santé tout autour.
Toute cette médecine du désir finalement,
ou du besoin pour quelque chose.
Donc ça, c'est vraiment conceptuellement,
c'est assez important.
C'est de cette différence là.
Voulu y ajouter quelque chose.
Développer le concept de santé
dans le monde militaire,
c'est c'est un peu différent.
D'abord, c'est de penser.
Rester en forme,
c'est rêver, c'est rester à son potentiel
pour pouvoir effectuer
une action militaire.
Donc ça, c'est c'est tout
médecin militaire et c'est son objectif
Pour rebondir à ce que vous dites,
il pourrait y avoir une petite
évolution
dans le monde de la santé militaire,
sous réserve
de ressources que nous n'avons pas.
Ça serait peut être une personnalisation
de la santé
en fonction de l'individu qui acquis
une médecine qui ne soit plus coachée
par quelqu'un qui vous suit
plus précisément comme un coach sportif.
Ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui, c'est
une médecine plutôt plutôt collective.
Sur ce qui est de la réparation,
alors là, on rejoint une question
qui est liée à un peu à l'anormalité.
D'abord, première chose.
Il est du devoir d'une nation,
d'un État de réparer ses soldats
qui sont blessés.
C'est un devoir moral que nous avons tous,
des gens
qui s'engagent
à risquer leur vie pour nous défendre où
il faut, il faut pouvoir les réparer.
C'est possible.
Donc on va,
on va mettre en sorte tous les moyens
pour qu'ils reviennent à une normalité
précédente.
Par exemple, si vous perdez une jambe,
on va vous mettre une prothèse
dans le futur.
On va se poser la question de vous réparer
pour atteindre un niveau de performance
peut être qui soit supérieur
à celui que vous aviez précédemment
grâce à cette prothèse.
Vous connaissez le sportif
Oscar Pistorius ?
Non, je mets de côté le fait
qu'il ait assassiné sa femme.
Ce qui est quand même moyen
en termes d'augmentation.
Mais il avait des prothèses
qui étaient un peu
des lames, ressorts
qui lui permettaient de courir plus vite.
Donc pourquoi des prothèses ?
Parce qu'il
avait un handicap à la naissance.
On a dû lui couper les jambes.
Donc il mettait
des prothèses et c'était un grand sportif.
Ce qu'il y a, c'est que ces prothèses
peuvent lui permettre de courir plus vite
qu'un individu normal.
Donc, il y a eu tout un débat
sur la normalité de ces prothèses.
Parce que si vous avez des lames
de ressorts qui vous permettent de courir,
vous allez peut être faire le 100 m
en huit secondes et non pas en secondes.
C'est à la fois dû à l'aspect sportif
de la personne,
mais aussi des prothèses qu'il porte.
Et donc là, on est dans une réparation
qui vous permet d'avoir des performances
au delà de la normalité.
Donc vous êtes augmenté.
La réparation peut amener
une augmentation, une étape en fait.
Finalement,
il faut aller vers l'augmentation.
Ce que vous disiez aussi avec les deux ?
Oui, c'est à dire
que si Pistorius avait gagné la médaille
d'or,
je ne sais pas ce qu'il se serait passé.
Mais il a eu une médaille d'argent
et ça a créé des débats juridiques.
Oui, il a d'abord été.
Il n'a pas été sélectionné au début
parce qu'on a eu peur.
Il passait de l'handicap ou
ou avec courir avec les personnes
qui n'étaient pas handicapés.
Mais il n'a pas fait quand même
une performance performance.
Parce que imaginer
qu'il y ait eu qu'il ait, qu'il ait gagné,
qu'il ait eu la médaille d'or, je le sais.
Je ne sais pas comment on aurait considéré
sa médaille.
Est ce que finalement, d'autres coureurs
auraient voulu se couper les jambes
et mettre des lames de carbone ?
Pourquoi pas pour gagner les courses ?
Et c'est un peu comme le dopage en sport.
Ou pourquoi ? Pourquoi freiner le dopage ?
Pourquoi freiner cette technologie
qui augmente qu'on n'arrive pas finalement
à bien faire, à bien faire
le distinguo entre amélioration,
augmentation et où ?
On n'arrive pas faire le distinguo,
on peut s'améliorer, s'améliorer
longtemps.
Et donc moi je pense que
heureusement que Pistorius n'a pas gagné.
Ça a permis de calmer les débats,
certainement.
Mais s'il avait gagné, je pense que
ça aurait posé de sacrés problèmes.
Ça devient une question de société,
effectivement.
Et d'ailleurs il existe des gens,
je le recommande pas.
Je crois que ça
s'appelle la tantôt Phyllis
qui quand des gens qui sont,
qui se coupent des membres
pour concourir dans le monde du handicap.
Oui, ça existe.
Je trouvais l'idée un peu folle,
mais finalement, et c'est une on va dire,
c'est une maladie psychique
qui a un nom là, tantôt
comme un nom de ce type.
Est ce qu'il y a des questions ?
Est ce que parmi vous, oui, monsieur,
on va vous donner un micro ?
Bonsoir, merci
que si ça marche,
on vous entend les chèques.
Bobrovsky.
Je suis chercheur à l'université Rennes
deux.
Philosophe, peut être.
Philosophe de l'art en tout cas.
Et donc, je voudrais d'abord
vous remercier
pour ces propos
introductifs.
Merci pour la clarté de la position
du côté de l'armée.
Je n'ai aucune question
qui me trouble.
Si par contre j'aimerais bien.
Je vous remercie d'avoir posé
la question du transhumanisme.
D'emblée
dans rappeller une histoire
que je voudrais compléter quand même
et vous poser des questions
autour de cela.
Julian Huxley, frère d'Aldous, qui a écrit
Le meilleur des mondes,
est une fiction eugéniste.
Par ailleurs,
était le premier président de l'Unesco en
46 48, je crois.
Et quand on lit la note philosophie.
l'Unesco en 46,
L'eugénisme, c'est cinq fois par page.
Et il invente le terme transhumanisme
parce qu'il se dit
on ne pourra plus défendre
l'eugénisme avec le mot eugénisme.
Après la guerre, même si personne
n'a été jugé pour ses folies eugénistes.
Donc je voudrais juste rappeler ce qu'est
l'eugénisme et vous demander de
de clarifier les propos
que vous avez tenus en disant
Julian Huxley en face pas un nazi.
Et bien sûr il n'est pas nazi.
Mais l'eugénisme c'est
une théorie
et une pratique qui a été inventée par
Sir Francis Galton
qui définissait l'eugénisme comme
la possibilité d'élever l'homme
comme on élève les bêtes et les plantes,
c'est à dire en croisant les espèces.
Ça a donné
tout le monde L'essai,
je crois à l'interdiction des mariages
entre le noir et blanc
jusque dans les années 70
aux États-Unis, l'élimination
des malades mentaux en Autriche
jusque dans les années 60 en Suède.
Enfin, parce que,
au lieu d'être augmenté, c'était
la dégénérescence humaine
qu'on poursuivait de diverses manières.
Et donc, grosso modo,
sur le plan idéologique,
c'est la bourgeoisie qui inventa
le mélange des sans que l'aristocratie
pratiquait depuis des siècles.
Donc, quand vous dites
cette transition, eugénisme
et transhumanisme,
j'aimerais bien être plus rassuré
sur ce que vous entendez par là.
Parce que Galton lui même, qui a inventé
cette théorie, n'est pas allé
beaucoup plus loin
que l'interdiction des mariages blancs,
mais par contre a failli
et produisait avec la photographie
des stéréotypes
des criminels, des enfants, des
fille de la tuberculose.
Et donc ça pose toute
une série de problèmes.
En quoi
les transhumanisme,
selon vous, serait différent
de l'eugénisme ?
En quoi Julian Huxley,
qui disait Les chevaux,
c'est 10 000 ans qu'on a dû
attendre à faire les croisements
des races.
L'homme, il faut aller plus vite,
mais ça impliquait
malgré tout les croisements
comme
comme la culture en face des animaux.
Vous voyez donc ?
Voilà. Merci pour la clarification.
Bon pour vous, merci pour ces
ces éléments d'information.
L'eugénisme de Galton
que le premier eugénisme darwinien.
Vraiment ? Pour essayer de prendre en main
l'amélioration de l'espèce
est un peu différent
de l'eugénisme qu'on peut qualifier
l'eugénisme d'aujourd'hui.
Finalement qu'est l'eugénisme, l'eugénisme
qui est plutôt libéral
et que nous avons tendance à accepter.
Mettre au monde des enfants handicapés
quand on peut ne pas les mettre au monde
par exemple.
Est ce que ce sera ce que ce ne sera pas
vu comme quelque chose de moralement
souhaitable et si c'est vu comme
quelque chose de moralement souhaitable ?
Peut être que si on peut
détecter les maladies, on peut aujourd'hui
détecter les maladies in utero.
À ce moment là, mettre au monde
un enfant handicapé sans avoir pris soin
de faire les et de s'informer.
Peut être que ce sera moralement condamné.
Et cette eugénisme là,
c'est un eugénisme discret qui s'infiltre
et qui est un eugénisme finalement
de domination sur la nature.
On ne laisse pas faire la nature comme ça
et on a un rapport à la nature
qui n'est pas
quelque chose qui nous est donné.
Mais c'est quelque chose
sur lequel on veut avoir une maîtrise.
Et l'eugénisme
participe de cette maîtrise là.
Et le transhumanisme
est quand même effectivement
dans cette maîtrise maîtrise scientifique,
maîtrise technologique
de toutes les imperfections de biologie
que nous les animaux humains,
on est quand même qu'on sent qu'on
va vieillir, on sent qu'on va,
on va être malade et on va disparaître.
Et la technologie vous propose,
vous propose des solutions et c'est et
c'est vraiment cette eugénisme là
qui est beaucoup plus discret
que nous allons,
que que nous avons tendance à accepter
ce n'est plus l'eugénisme de Galton
qui est vraiment révoltant, directement
révoltant, mais, mais c'est quand même
la même ligne d'amélioration de l'espèce.
Ça c'est vrai, c'est l'amélioration
de l'espèce et difficile de le refuser.
C'est là la subtilité.
Si vous voulez des propositions
transhumanisme, on vous propose,
moi, de vivre 30 ans de plus quand on est
déjà âgé, 30 ans de plus en bonne santé.
Est ce qu'on dit non en bonne santé ?
Est ce qu'on va dire non.
On a tendance à accepter et c'est
nos capacités finalement, parce que
ces histoires là portent un peu
nos désirs, nos besoins profonds.
Et on a tendance à ne pas
à ne pas mettre de frein.
Et c'est là le piège. Pourquoi
est ce qu'on ne fait pas de foin ?
Parce qu'on ne réfléchit plus vraiment.
Peut être aussi
parce que c'est un être humain, Quoi ?
Qu'est ce que est
ce qu'une bonne vie vertueuse
finalement, pour parler comme
Qu'est ce qu'une bonne vie vertueuse ?
On ne se pose plus la question
et la technologie qui arrive
nous propose des solutions.
Chaque fois que nous avons un problème.
Et l'eugénisme
est dans cette ligne.
Du transhumanisme, bien sûr,
mais c'est un eugénisme beaucoup moins
ou beaucoup plus discret
qu'on accepte.
Dans le libéralisme, on accepte tout,
on accepte d'être surveillé, on accepte
qu'on accepte plein de choses.
Voilà la différence comme entre les deux.
Eugénisme quand même.
Moi je dis juste une chose,
je ne suis pas un philosophe,
mais la force d'une société,
c'est quand même la
la force, l'action qu'elle met
dans le soin des plus déshérités
ou ceux qui ont moins de chances
que les autres.
C'est la cohésion d'une société.
C'est aussi
d'accepter ces gens là. Attention
à cette classification
parce que le risque derrière,
c'est avec la technologie, c'est certains
auront accès à la technologie
et pas d'autres.
Faut pas se leurrer,
l'uniformité de la technologie
accessible à tous est un rêve.
C'est une utopie, ça n'arrivera pas.
Donc ça peut créer une différence
entre celui qui maîtrise la technologie
et le reste du monde qui ne va pas
les maîtriser.
Ça va créer des tensions
supériorité, rébellion et conflits.
Mais je sors du monde militaire.
Il y a une question.
Bonsoir Monsieur, Bonsoir.
Moi je voulais vous poser une question
La chance de l'être humain
c'est de n'être nulle
et désoeuvrée, incompétent.
Donc il lui faut dès le départ
travailler pour pouvoir résister.
Alors
pourquoi a t on inventé ce nom maintenant
de transhumanisme
ou dogme d'homme augmenté depuis quand ?
Parce que
la roue,
le cheval, l'arme à feu de sport,
il entend parler de ça.
C'est une augmentation de l'homme et c'est
depuis toujours
la fourrure pour pas avoir froid
parce qu'on est nu.
Voilà l'éducation
parce qu'on est incompétent.
Tout ça c'est une augmentation
depuis toujours.
En fait.
Donc pourquoi aujourd'hui
on met ce nouveau nom et de quoi ?
C'est le symptôme.
C'est vrai que vous nous aviez raconté
que porter des lunettes,
c'était une certaine augmentation.
Finalement,
porter des vêtements aussi. Oui, oui.
Est ce que ça nous aide à voir ?
Non, actuellement, c'est une réparation.
C'est
une réponse n'est pas une augmentation.
Les vêtements, la fourrure,
la voiture, c'est une protection,
oui, qui participe effectivement
à une meilleure résistance de l'homme.
Donc on augmente
ses capacités de résistance au froid.
C'est quelque chose qui est porté par soi
même.
L'arme, c'est un peu différent.
Vous êtes faites partie
d'un système qui est homme plus arme.
C'est à dire que l'arme que
vous avez, elle, a besoin de vous
pour faire quelque chose.
Donc il y a l'individu, effectivement tout
seul et l'individu au sein d'un système.
On en a parlé juste avant.
C'est, on va dire, l'individu
qui est inséré dans un système
presque hybride au système.
Là, on élargit le champ.
Mais l'homme augmenté au départ,
c'est juste l'homme
tout seul, presque nu,
avec des équipements qu'il porte,
mais sur lequel il a un effet sans,
sans action directe.
Il n'a pas besoin d'appuyer sur de faire
un raisonnement intellectuel pour utiliser
par exemple une armure.
C'est une, c'est une forme d'augmentation
parce que vous n'avez pas un raisonnement
servant ne travaille pas pour l'utiliser.
Par contre,
une arme technique, là votre c'est vous.
Vous vous êtes,
vous faites partie d'un système ?
Je ne sais pas si je suis très clair,
si je fais un distinguo
entre le passif, le porté passif
et l'action de l'homme sur un système.
Je voudrais vous poser une question
comment
est ce que vous faites ?
Est ce que vous faites vraiment
une différence
entre entre le fait
d'utiliser des technologies
avec des intelligences artificielles,
des algorithmes qui sont des technologies
finalement externes,
externes à l'organisme et des technologies
qui viendraient comme des greffons,
des greffons de biotechnologies
ou des molécules, des implants ?
Des choses comme ça.
Est ce qu'il
y a une différence conceptuelle importante
pour vous dans le monde militaire
ou est ce que c'est finalement
quelque chose qui passe de l'un à l'autre
comme ça ?
Donc elle est majeure
parce qu'il y a un côté invasif,
c'est à dire si c'est un système externe,
vous pouvez le retirer.
Il n'y a pas d'effet sur votre corps.
Donc, comme un exosquelette,
par exemple comme un exosquelette,
un exosquelette augmente
vos capacités, vos performances.
Donc quelque part, vous êtes augmenté,
vous courrez plus vite,
vous êtes plus résistant.
Mais lorsque vous l'enlever, vous êtes.
Vous redevenez un état initial
avec des technologies invasives,
vous mettez des implants sous la peau,
dans le cerveau, et cetera Là,
vous vous rentrez dans l'intégrité
de l'être humain.
Donc c'est une autre catégorie.
Et là, vous changez
l'intégrité de qu'est l'homme.
Donc là, l'armée est
extrêmement prudente là dessus.
Pour l'instant, sa réponse est c'est non.
Si on peut trouver un système
plutôt externe,
qui est ce qui se colle à l'homme,
voilà qui on parlera d'une augmentation,
mais qui est portée par l'homme
qui est extérieur à l'homme et qui pose
beaucoup moins de questions éthiques
dans le sens où elle n'affecte pas
l'intégrité de l'être humain.
Alors justement,
comment on augmente un soldat ?
Faisons un petit zoom
sur sur cette partie là.
Avec quel dispositif ?
Qu'est ce qui existe aujourd'hui
et qui pourrait exister ?
J'imagine
qu'on est loin du super héros de Marvel.
Est ce que vous pouvez
un peu nous dire ce que, en tout cas,
peut être, à l'état
de la recherche aujourd'hui aussi ?
Peut être que les dispositifs alors ?
D'abord, il y a beaucoup de fantasmes
et donc c'est important.
Il y a énormément de fantasmes.
Ne croyez pas que les armées ont
des laboratoires qui créent des choses,
en tout cas pas en France.
Donc on travaille essentiellement
sur les équipements.
Alors quels sont les équipements du futur
qui augmenteraient
les performances de l'homme ?
On a cité l'exosquelette.
Je peux marcher beaucoup plus longtemps.
Je pourrais faire une action dans la durée
en me fatiguant moins.
Ça, c'est un exemple.
Il y a tout ce qui est meilleure
protection.
Je reviens à l'armure du Moyen-Age
au Moyen-Age.
Vous avez des armures
pour résister aux coups et flèches.
Et puis elles sont tombées
complètement en désuétude parce que
l'arme à feu est arrivée demain.
On peut imaginer que si je crée une armure
qui est qui permet de parer les balles,
tous les soldats vont de nouveau
est équipé
d'une certaine armure
pour arrêter les balles.
C'est l'histoire qui va se répéter.
S'arrêtera peut être pas les missiles
on est d'accord,
mais ça arrêtera les balles.
Donc l'histoire va se répéter.
Donc protection Après
il y a tout ce qui est se plonger dans
alors là, c'est le cognitif,
c'est avoir une meilleure
perception de l'environnement du terrain,
ce qu'on appelle l'environnement tactique,
mieux comprendre ce qui se passe.
Donc, ce sont devant,
devant vos lunettes de réalité
augmentée par exemple,
vous avez, vous voyez ce que vous voyez ?
Se rajoute des informations
sur la position de l'ennemi,
la position des amis,
le nombre de munitions qui vous reste,
ce que vous voulez.
Un compas, c'est un ordinateur.
Finalement, c'est une interface
avec un ordinateur qui vous permet
d'avoir des informations supplémentaires
que vous n'auriez pas de façon
classique.
Donc ça, c'est aussi un grand niveau
d'augmentation
pour tout ce qui est plutôt invasif. Là,
il n'y a pas grand chose,
il y a la pharmacologie.
Je vous ai cité quelques exemples
dans l'histoire,
donc il y a notamment des psychostimulants
pour rester éveillé.
Mais vous avez peut être entendu
parler du mode Affinis,
qui était une substance qui a été utilisée
jusqu'à récemment dans les armées,
mais qui vient d'être plus ou moins
retirée dans l'armée française.
En tout cas parce qu'on peut repousser
les limites du sommeil.
C'est un psychostimulant,
mais ça permet de rester éveillé.
Mais au bout d'un moment, le corps humain,
on parlait de limite.
Il y aura toujours ces limites
vis à vis du sommeil.
Et si à un moment
il ne dort pas bien, vous mourrez.
On meurt de ne pas dormir.
Donc repousser indéfiniment
les limites du soldat face au sommeil,
ce n'est pas possible.
À un moment,
il faut s'arrêter et parfois on
croit bien faire.
Et l'effet sur la durée n'est pas bon.
Je prends l'exemple des Allemands en 1940
qui utilisaient une substance qui était
la vitamine qui les empêche de dormir.
Ça a marché au début
et la campagne de France a beaucoup marché
au moment de l'utiliser et on a.
C'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
on a perdu la bataille de France.
Mais à long terme, les Allemands,
les soldats allemands,
sont devenus dépendants
de cette substance.
Ils sont devenus accros
et leurs performances vont faire du temps.
Au fur et à mesure du temps, c'est baissé
et ils étaient moins performants
sur la fin de la guerre.
Qu'est
ce que je pourrais vous dire d'autre ?
Les dispositifs dont vous parliez,
ils existent déjà.
Certains militaires en sont déjà munis
ou c'est à l'état de la recherche
en cours de développement.
Alors il y a un projet en France
de la Direction générale de l'armement
qui s'appelle le projet Centurion
sur les équipements du futur,
sur le combattant.
C'est une meilleure interface,
une meilleure communication
avec les autres, une meilleure protection.
On reste dans l'externe,
on reste dans l'externe.
Les substances
pharmacologiques,
il y en a très, très peu.
Alors je vous parle de la France.
Il y a des pays qui font différemment,
les cadres sont différents
et parce que le cadre éthique
est différent.
Et ça peut peut
être des positions éthiques.
Mais on en parle peut être parce que là,
il y a une vraie question philosophique.
Y a deux questions, trois questions.
On vous écoute ? Bonsoir.
Alors là, vous nous avez dit pardon ?
Quelques mots sur la recherche, l'état
de la recherche actuelle
sur l'homme augmenté, le soldat augmenté.
Mais j'imagine quand même que jusqu'à
un certain point,
il faut que ça reste un peu secret.
On ne va pas donner à l'ennemi
tout, on va pas tout dire à l'ennemi.
Donc ça, c'est une chose.
Et d'un autre côté,
qu'on l'a vu à plusieurs reprises,
on l'a mentionné,
ça soulève des problèmes éthiques.
Le fait d'augmenter nos soldats ?
Alors là, du coup, je me dis
il y a quand même une tension
parce que si c'est privé, si c'est secret,
ça veut dire que le public
ne peut pas s'emparer
de ces débats
là, discuter de ces questions.
Donc du coup, comment ça se passe ?
Est ce qu'il y a un comité éthique
interne à l'armée qui en discute ?
Mais du coup, on n'est pas au courant,
non ?
Excellente question. Merci.
Et bien la France était assez exemplaire
dans ce domaine.
Elle est le seul pays au monde
à avoir créé un comité d'éthique
sur les questions de défense.
Donc c'est la ministre des armées
précédente, madame Florence Parly,
qui l'a créée en 2020.
De mémoire, et le premier sujet
qui a été mis sur la table,
c'est le soldat augmenté.
Donc on a été audité à Saint-Cyr
justement parce qu'on avait travaillé
sur ces questions.
Et nous, on écoutait et on avait mis
certaines limites éthiques.
Je peux vous en citer deux
qu'on avait mises.
On avait dit à l'augmentation oui,
sauf si ça,
si ça fait une atteinte à la liberté
de pensée ou de conscience
de l'être humain.
C'est à dire que si je vous donne
une substance qui qui détruit
votre empathie ou qui me permet un peu
de prendre le contrôle de votre esprit,
et cetera, ou qui vous empêche
ce libre arbitre
sur le terrain, Niet, c'est inacceptable.
Donc c'est le premier critère
qu'on a mis, c'est garder l'humanité.
Son humanité, c'est garder
l'humanité propre,
les êtres humains et doit rester humain
doit rester.
C'est exactement ça.
Et le deuxième limite qu'on avait mis,
il y en a d'autres,
mais qu'on avait vraiment mis en avant,
c'était de ne pas toucher à l'intégrité
complète de l'être humain.
Alors quand je dis intégrité complète,
c'est corps et âme.
Corps, c'est vous avez un corps.
l'Esprit, c'est c'est votre, c'est
le cognitif, c'est un intellectuel.
Mais il y a aussi
la transcendance de l'action
qui peut, qui peut pâtir
d'une augmentation, c'est
à dire vous augmenter,
pas un côté pour réduire de l'autre.
Vous êtes complet tel que vous êtes
et je ne veux pas
faire une distorsion dans un sens
plutôt qu'un autre.
Il faut rester équilibré.
On va dire.
Par exemple, si je vous fais des actions
sur le cerveau, vous êtes,
Je vais être augmenté une partie
de votre cerveau pour avoir une meilleure.
Je ne fait pas communication au langage
perception, vote
au détriment de certaines capacités
motrices ou de votre capacité de
métaphysique,
de prise de recul dans le sens
mais dans le sens prise de recul, force
d'âme, prise
de recul métaphysique.
Et donc, c'est
un comité qui réunit régulièrement.
Ce comité se réunit régulièrement.
Le deuxième sujet, Ça tombe bien,
on travaillait aussi dessus.
C'était tout ce qui était
un robot autonome avec une létalité.
Troisième sujet, ça a été le numérique
dans les armées et ça continue.
Ça continue, c'est on est le seul pays
au monde à pour l'instant.
Pour l'instant,
parce que je pense qu'on va,
on va donner l'exemple à faire ça,
sachant que d'autres pays
font plutôt de l'expérimentation.
Avant de se poser la question
de savoir si c'est bien ou pas.
Je cite de très grands pays du monde qui
ont beaucoup d'argent à mettre là dedans.
Voilà,
il y avait
d'autres questions il me semble,
et je suis désolé de reprendre la parole,
mais j'ai deux questions supplémentaires.
Les dernières.
On vous écoute avec Brovsky, donc
la première, c'est que nous,
on parle d'eugénisme,
des transhumanisme, de l'homme augmenté.
Mais vous donner l'exemple
d'un embryon
qu'on avorte parce qu'il est malade,
je vois rien d'augmenter,
ça ne produit pas de conséquences
sur l'espèce.
Donc j'aimerais bien que vous précisions
en quoi on pourrait penser
l'augmentation
au niveau l'espèce de l'espèce.
Je me permets de deuxième question
parce que les deux sont liés.
Est ce que pour vous,
philosophe, l'homme
est une espèce, donc
concept biologique
ou est ce que c'est un concept politique ?
Si c'est un concept biologique,
comment vous en tracer la limite ?
Le périmètre,
étant donné que tous les dangers
du racisme a été inhérent
à l'eugénisme,
alors ?
Concernant la première question,
je disais simplement
qu'il
y a une amélioration générale de l'espèce.
C'est ça que je voulais dire
et c'est l'eugénisme
qui qui améliore
d'une façon générale l'espèce.
Mais mais il y a eu jeunisme également.
À partir du moment où on peut
effectivement entrer dans les modes de la,
dans les modes de reproduction
où on peut par exemple choisir
les types de types d'enfants
que nous pourrions avoir.
Si on laisse faire la nature, c'est rempli
de choses extravagantes,
c'est rempli de surprises.
Quand on a un enfant, on tient,
il est comme ça.
Tiens, c'est un garçon, tiens, et cetera
Donc il.
Il a une sorte de liberté finalement,
parce qu'il arrive un peu par hasard.
Mais s'il est programmé,
s'il est programmé,
ça change beaucoup de choses
et donc, si vous voulez,
cet eugénisme de programmation
est quasiment souhaitable.
C'est à dire
que quand on quand on veut se reproduire,
on projette beaucoup sur sur.
Sur ces enfants, on projette des choses
et si on peut les profiter
encore plus,
Est ce qu'on va refuser ces questions là ?
Mais ça déborde un peu la. Question de
la question du transhumanisme.
Alors, la définition de l'homme ?
Vous savez, moi j'ai pas beaucoup de gens,
Pour beaucoup l'opinion,
j'ai la philosophie.
Il y a une clarification conceptuelle.
On essaye de clarifier conceptuellement.
Pour Aristote, l'homme
est un animal politique absolument.
Ici, il faut se poser les questions
où on a posé.
On a amené des termes tout à fait
impressionnants, comme le terme d'âme,
le thème de libre arbitre, qui sont des
qui sont des thèmes de la philosophie
et de la religion et qui sont encore
très discutés en philosophie.
On se demande si le libre arbitre existe
vraiment, si cette chose là que nous avons
de mettre en route, de mettre en route
des nouveaux chemins Coso.
Est ce que ça existe vraiment ?
Et il faut pour rebondir sur
votre intervention ?
On a l'impression dans l'intervention,
dans l'intervention ici
qu'on essaye de préserver l'homme.
Quand même au sein de cette technologie,
de le garder, son intégrité,
et cetera Mais, mais je me demandais,
en ce qui concerne les prises de décision,
les prises de décision qui sont associées
certainement à des algorithmes de calcul
de la conséquence de l'acte,
qui sont beaucoup plus puissants
que nos propres calculs
de la conséquence de l'acte.
Nous, quand nous jouons aux échecs,
on peut calculer cinq coups à l'avance.
Jouer ça, il va jouer ça,
je vais faire ça.
Mais une machine,
on sait très bien qu'un ordinateur,
tout le monde aux échecs, c'est vraiment
inintéressant de jouer aux échecs
puisque non
seulement la machine ne sait même pas
quelque chose d'échecs
et nous aplatit tout le temps.
Donc ça n'a aucun intérêt,
mais elle est capable en tout cas
de faire un calcul de la conséquence.
En ce qui concerne
les situations militaires, il y a.
Il y a donc un champ, un champ militaire,
un champ de bataille militaire
et il y a des décisions à prendre.
Et ces décisions
dans ce que vous dites, vous dites
et on essaie de préserver l'humain
dans son intégrité.
Vous avez amené différents concepts
qui appuient cette intégrité,
mais les prises de décision
ne sont pas mieux prises
par des par des machines qui vont
faire un calcul beaucoup plus puissant
que tout calcul que que moi je pourrais
faire si j'étais militaire jusque là.
À ce moment là.
Est ce qu'on n'est pas
finalement une entité dans la technologie,
un rouage dans la machine
et là, l'intégrité de l'homme
que vous avez parlé, dont vous avez parlé
avec le libre arbitre, l'homme, et cetera
Est ce qu'on n'est pas ?
Est ce qu'elle ne fait pas dissoute
finalement
avec ces algorithmes
qui prendront de meilleures décisions ?
Sans doute.
L'homme, quelle place pour l'homme ?
Réponse réponse C'est non.
Je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous
pour plusieurs raisons.
D'abord, la machine, effectivement,
est plus efficace que l'homme
dans des calculs,
dans la performance de ses calculs.
Si l'espace dans lequel l'algorithme
intervient est borné.
Je suis ingénieur de formation
et j'ai fait de l'algorithme.
J'ai développé
des systèmes algorithmiques.
Ce sont toujours des systèmes
qui sont bornés,
avec un certain nombre de paramètres,
d'entrées, de paramètres, de sortie.
Là, la machine, effectivement,
peut être plus performante que l'homme.
C'est le jeu d'échecs, c'est le jeu de go.
Voilà,
maintenant,
l'homme a une capacité de prise
de recul, de créativité
que n'aura pas
une machine, aussi puissante soit elle.
Elle sera toujours limitée par les
ce qu'on appelle les input,
les paramètres en entrée et donc
dans le cadre dans lequel elle évolue.
La force de l'homme,
c'est de sortir de ce cadre.
Et il y a quelque chose dans l'homme
que vous n'aurez
probablement jamais dans la machine.
J'aimerais
prendre un exemple,
mais il est un tout petit peu long à dire.
Je vais le dire tout de même, c'est
un raid blindé pour aller
délivrer un président africain
qui est en mauvaise posture.
Ça se passe en Côte d'Ivoire.
Euh, c'est le président Gbagbo
et la France décide
de faire en sorte que ce président
qui est assiégé dans son
parlement ne soit pas massacré.
Donc fait un raid blindé.
C'est à dire que vous avez des blindés
qui vont très très vite pour le libérer.
Ils ont des centaines de kilomètres
à faire donc ils font à fond, à fond.
Et là, vous avez un ordre politique
qui vient du président de
la République français.
Donc le chef des armées, alors là,
ça fonce.
Donc vous avez
toute la hiérarchie militaire
qui dit aller à fond, à fond, à fond.
Et il y a un lieutenant que.
Je connais qui est avec ses blindés,
qui va très vite comme ça
et ils arrivent à un carrefour
dans un village et il s'arrête.
Qu'est ce que tu fais ?
Pourquoi tu t'arrêtes ?
Je le sens pas,
tu le sens pas.
Faut y aller. Non, je le sens pas.
Donc il envoie ce qu'on appelle une sonde.
Voilà quelqu'un qui va repérer qui revient
et qui dit j'ai rien vu, c'est bon.
Et donc là,
la hiérarchie dit fonce, c'est un ordre.
Non, je ne le sens pas, je ne le sens pas.
Il envoie une deuxième sonde
qui est la même personne. D'ailleurs,
quelqu'un qui a de l'expérience
m'a dit Tu vas refaire un coup de sonde.
Le gars refais un coup de sonde
et il découvre ce qu'on appelle un char
embossé, c'est à dire un char
qui est caché.
On voit juste la tourelle qui sort
qui pointe le carrefour
sur lequel les Français doivent passer.
Là, il revient en disant Oui,
effectivement, là, il y a un problème.
Si on passe, on se fait tirer dessus.
Rapport au capitaine.
Alors effectivement, oui, peut être.
Bon maintenant dépêchez vous, allez
y, il n'y en a qu'un et je le sens pas
et renvoie
une troisième fois
une sonde qui voit en fait trois chars
Embossé.
Cette prise de décision
de ce chef militaire contre la hiérarchie,
contre le contre
la réalité que tout le monde perçoit
sauf lui, ça,
c'est cette transcendance humaine
qui qui fait qu'il y a une prise de recul,
un nouveau paramètre,
un certain nombre de paramètres
qui sont pris en compte, qui sont peut
être le fruit de l'intuition, de là
comme vous voulez, ou de l'expérience
qui fait qu'il n'est pas passé comme ça.
Donc il y a eu un voilà.
Il a réussi à déloger les chars
et ensuite à poursuivre
Son unité a perdu peut être 1 h là dessus,
mais il a sauvé ses hommes
et le président Gbagbo
a été libéré dans la foulée.
Je prends cet exemple
parce que je pense que jamais une machine
ne sera capable de faire ça.
Mais une machine est plus performante
que l'homme.
Je suis d'accord avec vous.
On va encore prendre deux questions
ou trois sera la dernière.
On vous écoute, monsieur
marche pas, vous m'entendez ?
Christophe Le Rat, école des hautes études
en santé publique à Rennes.
En vous entendant,
je me pose vraiment une question sur
nos systèmes démocratiques.
Est ce que, en fait,
le transhumanisme ne vient pas
complètement questionner,
percuter l'idéal démocratique ?
Et donc c'est quoi les garde fous ?
Parce qu'on peut supposer
ce que vous décrivez, ce qui se passe
en France où, au niveau militaire,
il y a la possibilité de discuter,
d'avoir un véritable débat
éthique, et cetera
Mais c'est en France
et au niveau international
quel est l'organe qui est en capacité
de discuter de ce sujet ?
C'est l'ONU,
C'est c'est qui ? C'est quoi ?
Parce que potentiellement
un certain nombre de pays,
je n'hésiterai pas.
Mais on se dit le transhumanisme
ou on peut s'en servir de façon
totalement dévoyée.
Il y a une vraie interrogation
par rapport à ça.
Est ce
qu'il y a un cadre international
finalement ?
Il y a des chercheurs
ou même des gens de gens importants.
Je pense à Stephen Hawking,
qui était un chercheur, et il avait signé
avec, je crois, même
Bill Gates.
Un article comme quoi.
Concernant les armes,
il fallait absolument pas qu'il y ait
des armes offensives autonomes et que.
Et que
ça faisait vraiment peur
et qu'ils voulaient freiner
le développement de l'IA, justement.
Mais ils parlaient
en tant que l'un industriel, l'autre
s'occupant d'astrophysique.
On voit bien combien ils étaient démunis
à poser cette question là
et il est vrai, en ce qui concerne à fond
en dehors du monde militaire
que je connais très peu.
Mais ce qu'on peut,
ce qu'on peut voir dans les entreprises ou
dans les entreprises,
il s'agit d'un marché
capitaliste extraordinaire,
le marché des data.
Et là, ça se développe,
ça se développe pour un profit maximum
de ces entreprises là.
Et là, il n'y a pas de garde fou.
Ce n'est pas démocratique.
Une entreprise n'est
pas un lieu de démocratie, il me semble.
La démocratie c'est dans la société,
c'est pas dans l'entreprise et donc
ça se développe tant que c'est rentable et
ça avance, ça avance donc effectivement.
Et même en ce qui concerne la science,
on sait très bien qu'il
y a un problème de démocratie
sur les prises de décision scientifiques
et c'est pour ça que le transhumanisme
a beaucoup d'adversaires
ou des adversaires qui s'organisent donc
et donc
votre question est pose effectivement
et pose effectivement le problème
de la démocratie de ces développements là.
Mais ça se fait à l'intérieur
d'un ordre capitaliste, il faut le dire.
Ce n'est pas prendre une peu
prendre position en disant ça l'est
dans un monde concurrentiel
et capitaliste.
Et c'est à l'intérieur de ce monde là
que cela se développe,
avec toutes les inégalités
que cela génère.
Et donc cette peur
d'un développement non contrôlé
dans la tête de personnes.
On voit bien qu'il y a un problème.
Effectivement, à part ça, je peux vous
en dire plus qu'il y a un problème.
Je parle comme vous finalement,
on a l'impression qu'il y a un problème.
Moi je rejoins tout à fait l'argent VA
va abolir beaucoup de barrières et
ça va pousser.
Dès qu'il y a du dès qu'il
y a du marché ou une créativité de marché.
Les choses vont arriver
et ce n'est pas forcément bien.
Je suis tout à fait d'accord.
Moi, je ne connais pas d'instance
internationale qui puisse brider
certains pays totalitaires
de plus d'un milliard de personnes
qui ont une vision collective
de la société
et pas du tout de l'individu.
Ils sont, ils pensent pas comme nous,
ils ne pensent pas comme nous et demain
ils vont peut être dominer la planète.
Donc l'éthique collective,
ça rejoint un peu l'éthique des pays.
Nous, on a une éthique très
centrée sur l'homme.
Vous l'avez dit ?
Non, l'homme,
c'est non, c'est le groupe ou la
le parti qui est.
Donc ils vont faire des expérimentations,
des tests, et cetera
Je prends juste un exemple aujourd'hui
le contrôle du cerveau.
Ils développent ça
sur les pilotes de train.
Ils ont des sortes
de capteurs, de l'activité cérébrale
et si quelqu'un s'endort,
vous avez des stimuli qui le réveille ?
C'est bien, c'est bien sur le principe.
Par contre, dans l'utilisation,
on voit bien que c'est
comme le problème de la technologie.
Ça c'est neutre ça.
Voilà, c'est bien ou c'est mal, ça dépend
comment on l'utilise et ça,
c'est l'éthique
d'un pays qui va répondre à ça.
Mais je ne connais pas d'instances
internationales qui va, qui va gérer ça ?
Il y a une question
chacun votre tout,
Jean-François.
Oui, c'était un peu par rapport
à la discussion qu'on vient d'avoir.
Est ce que vous avez dit ?
Est ce qu'on est ce qu'on pourrait définir
un peu l'homme
augmenté à partir
des propos que vous avez tenu sur le fait
effectivement que l'homme augmenté
a subi des technologies invasives
et qu'on touche à l'intégrité de l'humain
avec en changeant
les possibilités initiales ?
Est ce qu'on peut dire
que ça peut donner une définition
intéressante de ce qu'il a augmenté ?
La perspective de l'homme augmenté,
c'est la disparition de disparition
de la biologie.
Vraiment, la biologie, c'est ce qui, c'est
ce qui freine le développement
de la technique qu'on est donc
dans la disparition de la biologie.
Et là, il y a
donc toutes ces toutes ces machineries
qui peuvent occuper notre corps.
Mais ça va même encore plus loin
puisqu'ils ont une certaine idée
même de l'esprit
puisque ça reste de la science fiction.
Mais c'est quand même vraiment discuté.
D'un point de vue théorique,
c'est le fait de télécharger
l'esprit dans une machine.
On se parait complètement dingue,
mais ça dépend
de ce que l'on appelle l'esprit
et ce qu'on appelle l'esprit.
Il y en a peut être
pas besoin de la conscience
qu'il a conscience de ce que nous,
la conscience phénoménale
qui a l'air vraiment très particulière,
à nous les êtres sensibles.
Mais on peut imaginer, et ça,
ça fait vraiment partie des projets.
Si vous lisez les Prédictions
de cœur de Raymond Kurzweil, par exemple,
cet ingénieur en chef
développement chez Google,
il pense qu'il
y aura un point de singularité,
donc un point de modification
complètement de l'espèce.
Et parmi ce point de singularité,
il aura la possibilité de se télécharger
dans une machine. Et c'est vrai
qu'ils ont envie.
Si on envisage des voyages intégrés aussi
des très très loin,
le corps ne suffit pas et donc un corps
hybride qu'on imagine mal.
Mais en tout cas quelque chose qui fait
qu'on peut se télécharger.
Mais pour se télécharger dans une machine,
ça c'est bizarre.
On perd complètement
le fait que nous soyons des organismes.
Alors la définition du transhumanisme,
le post humain,
le post humain, le transhumanisme
étant la transition, le post humain,
c'est un être humain
qui est relativement débarrassé
de tous les aspects biologiques
qui font toute notre faiblesse,
tout notre charme sans doute,
mais qui fait que nous tombons malades,
que nous sommes fatigués.
On a envie d'en,
mais on ne peut pas toujours être efficace
et donc l'hybridation avec les machines
va vraiment très très,
très loin dans les prévisions.
Donc le transhumanisme,
c'est le premier pas vers le post humain.
Et donc
voilà la définition en perspective,
en tout cas du transhumanisme.
Elle est vraiment posée comme ça.
Bon, dans le monde militaire,
ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens.
Le militaire y part d'un individu
qui est ça peut et c'est
toute personne ici qui il y avait
la conscription avant en cas de conflit.
Vous parlez de l'individu tel qu'il est
et vous le formez
pour qu'il
puisse effectuer une mission militaire.
Donc ça, ça parle de l'homme tel qu'il
est, avec toute sa dimension physique
d'ailleurs, qui lui permet
d'agir sur son environnement.
Donc, l'idée de l'augmentation du soldat,
c'est
d'aller au delà de ses limites pour durer.
Pour voilà, pour être plus efficient
et pour durer dans son action militaire.
Voilà, ce n'est plus
une question de.
Il y avait encore une question devant
et une question tout au fond il me semble.
On va prendre,
on va prendre ces deux dernières là. Oui,
oui, mais
il y a le monsieur devant toi Olivier,
on va commencer là.
Merci.
C'était pour compléter
ma première question,
il y a dans cette course à l'échalote
de l'homme augmenté.
La technique et les data sont une source
historiquement,
une chance qui n'a jamais été aussi forte
sans doute qu'aujourd'hui.
Est ce que ce n'est pas une traduction
d'une chute justement
de la transcendance ?
Peur de mourir,
donc. Avant, on n'avait pas peur.
Si on croyait en Dieu,
c'était presque une bénédiction.
Mais aujourd'hui, toutes ces transcendance
n'existent
probablement plus de façon authentique.
Est ce que ça traduit pas justement
cette course à l'échalote de l'homme
augmenté une chute des valeurs
transcendant tout ? Moi,
je suis d'accord avec vous.
Pour moi,
la définition telle qu'elle a été
précisée, pour moi, c'est une dépression.
C'est un
symptôme de dépression de l'homme, quoi.
On ne croit plus en ce qu'on est,
on refuse nos faiblesses
et donc on ne s'aime plus.
Je bon, personnellement, c'est
une réponse personnelle.
Je pense qu'il
faut s'aimer avec nos faiblesses.
Nous sommes comme ça.
On est conscient de nos limites.
On en aura toujours, on va mourir.
Je suis désolé de vous dire ça, mais
je ne crois pas à l'immortalité du corps.
Je crois à celle de l'âme.
Et ça, c'est
la religion qui donne cette réponse.
Mais l'immortalité du corps.
Je pense d'ailleurs
que ce n'est pas à souhaiter.
Et il est vrai qu'on peut rapprocher
les prédictions transhumanistes.
On peut les rapprocher
finalement des religions.
Jusque là, le concept d'immortalité,
il était porté par les religions.
Et si on n'avait pas de religion,
il peut être porté
par ce que nous laissons
finalement aux uns, aux autres nos œuvres,
notre travail, tout.
On laisse tous quelque chose qui nous.
Qui finalement distille
cette immortalité ?
C'est tout ce qu'on veut, c'est
tout ce que nous avions jusque là.
Mais avec le transhumanisme,
on vous propose un concept d'immortalité
technologique
et tout à fait impressionnant
et qui fait que bien
on retombe dans des fautes
un peu originelles qu'on trouve dans
la Bible où l'homme est pris d'une hubris
et il se prend pour Dieu, non pas par pas
le Dieu transcendant, mais le dieu grec,
espèce de Superman,
qui est capable de faire plein de choses.
Mais vivre au delà, au delà de
au delà de 120 ans, par exemple,
est quand même un projet très construit,
très construit par des entreprises
qui visent 500 600 ans.
D'accord, mais en bonne santé.
Sera très très loin.
Comment la retraite ?
Ce que ça va poser des problèmes ?
Plusieurs types de problèmes. 572 ans. Là,
je ne sais pas quoi ressemblerait, mais
c'est dingue.
Mais disons
il y a effectivement une prise en main
de ce que nous faisions
avec le concept d'immortalité.
Il y a une prise en main technologique
de ce concept là
et je crois que je vais émettre une idée.
Je crois que ce n'est pas bon
que la techno s'occupe de tout.
Nous ne sommes pas seulement face
à des problèmes techniques,
mais là, vraiment, on nous propose
l'immortalité technologique.
Une dernière question.
Bonsoir, bonsoir !
Véritable défi
que de poser une question synthétique
après tout ce qui a été exposé.
Une première qui me vient à l'esprit,
enfin,
que mon frère a soufflé
le soldat sur le terrain quand il combat
pour être plus performant,
s'améliore
mais s'améliore
d'outils technologiques. Et
c'est vous parliez de
l'exosquelette, le char,
les fusils, règle générale.
l'Armée est de plus en plus technologique,
technique.
On ne se bat plus avec ses poings
afin de moins en moins et
à l'heure.
Je ne sais pas si c'est possible, mais
admettons qu'il y ait une tempête solaire.
Beaucoup des systèmes
technologiques qui servent
à combattre
seraient peut être réduits à néant.
Et donc ma question serait quid
de celle de l'armée,
peut importe quelle qu'elle soit,
en cas de tempête solaire majeure
ou tout simplement
en cas de problème sociétal,
parce que l'armée dépend
d'une industrie complexe.
Et cette industrie,
ce sont des travailleurs
et donc la chaîne est très complexe,
très vaste.
Donc pour pouvoir faire la guerre,
il faut tout un pays derrière
et même plusieurs fois.
Et ma question est
un peu plus vaste.
J'ai déjà une réponse à ce que vous avez
dit, alors ce serait une question.
Après peut être Monsieur le philosophe,
le soldat,
à l'heure de la tempête solaire, démuni,
se retrouve un peu seul face à lui même.
Et qu'est ce qui a évolué
finalement chez lui ?
Qu'est ce qu'il a augmenté ?
Il a augmenté finalement l'extérieur,
mais il n'a pas véritablement
augmenté l'intérieur
durant les siècles qui ont passé.
On a tenté de développer l'intérieur,
on a tenté de
l'augmentation
était synonyme de sanctification,
d'évolution spirituelle, et cetera
Et donc, je trouve ça curieux que
le thème de ce soir,
ce soit le transhumanisme qui est
une évolution technique qui n'est pas
une évolution qui n'est pas l'évolution.
L'évolution est plus vaste,
ça va chercher
l'eugénisme,
ça va chercher la technologie.
Mais peut être aussi
qu'il y a une réflexion à voir
sur l'évolution de
peut être de nos consciences
qui sont quand même à l'origine de tout,
de tout évolution,
qu'elles soient eugénistes,
technologiques ou autres.
Et donc je voulais savoir.
J'étais curieux que vous disiez
que le transhumanisme était un terme
inventé par Julien Oxley
ou il m'avait semblé
que c'était un certain Jean Coutrot
qui était à l'origine du terme
et qui avait fondé un institut,
je crois, des problèmes humains en France.
Cet institut avait vocation
à questionner le devenir de l'humanité,
le prendre en main éventuellement et
sans forcément
qu'on aille vers un avenir technologique.
C'est à dire que la question était
peut être encore plus vaste
et qu'on voyait les choses avec
plus de largeur d'esprit.
Et donc, pour ma question finale sera
pourquoi ?
Pourquoi avons nous choisi une évolution
plutôt qu'une autre ?
Alors il y a 32 questions
dans votre exposé.
Il faut qu'on synthétise.
Je vais répondre pour le soldat,
puis je laisserai après
à mon collègue de répondre.
En fait, vous parlez de technologie,
alors je vais vous faire
la réponse suivante
la technologie est nécessaire au soldat
pour gagner la bataille.
Une bataille ?
Les batailles sont d'emblée
dans les conflits, au départ
très technologiques, pour pouvoir acquérir
une suprématie aérienne
ou sur le terrain, et cetera
Donc, on l'a vu, ça se voit partout.
Donc le début, la première phase,
Ce volet de la guerre
est très technologique
parce qu'avec cette technologie,
vous êtes plus forts que l'adversaire,
vous pointez votre adversaire
avec le temps.
Et il n'y a pas besoin de tempête solaire.
Avec le temps,
vos matériels sont détruits,
vous avez moins de munitions
intelligentes,
des missiles super sophistiqués
qui coûtent extrêmement cher.
Vous n'avez pas des stocks
infinis. C'est le problème des Russes
aujourd'hui.
Donc vous rentrez dans une deuxième phase
qui est une bataille qui devient de moins
en moins technologique.
Et là, c'est la force morale du soldat,
c'est la force collective qui l'emporte.
Une nation,
si elle n'est pas forte, s'effondre.
D'ailleurs, c'est un peu un gros sujet
au niveau politique
et au chef d'état major des armées
aujourd'hui,
est ce que notre nation est suffisamment
forte, résiliente
si elle se fait attaquer ?
Et je vous laisse à la réponse.
Mais on a quelques réflexions là dessus.
Donc cette deuxième phase,
comment on se forme à ça ?
Alors ça, c'est de tradition militaire
depuis longtemps à Saint-Cyr.
Qu'est ce qu'on fait ?
L'élève officier qui arrive,
qui comme vous et qui veut être officier
pendant un an,
on le met sur le terrain, dans la boue,
avec un treillis et une arme.
Et c'est tout.
Et pendant un an,
il répète des gestes indéfiniment.
Donc c'est dur, Il fait froid,
il pleut, c'est un peu répétitif.
Alors qu'il pourrait être au chaud
avec de la technique.
Et on démarre par ça,
parce que ça, ça imprègne le cerveau
et ça lui permet de se connaître,
de connaître ses limites, mais de savoir
aussi aller au delà de limites.
On parle d'augmentation.
L'augmentation n'est crédible que
si vous connaissez vos limites et en fait,
on est toujours capable
de repousser un peu ses limites.
Ça, c'est la base.
Et nous, cette base là, on l'enseigne.
Je vous dis d'emblée aux élèves officiers
et pour qu'ils aient conscience
qu'on peut toujours aller plus loin
quelque part sans la technique.
Mais la technique est nécessaire
pour quand même gagner les batailles,
pas forcément la guerre.
J'ai pas dit la guerre,
mais gagner les batailles.
Donc voilà ce que je voulais vous donner
comme réponse.
Ensuite, je vous avez parlé de conscience,
d'héritage, de force morale
ou spirituelle ou autre.
Moi, personnellement,
je ne crois pas que la machine,
un jour une conscience,
c'est l'être humain qui a une conscience.
C'est
ce que vous expliquez tout à l'heure.
Donc j'y crois,
mais je laisse la mémoire, la conclusion ?
Non, non, mais vous avez eu une question
qui était très complexe.
Mais je pense aussi à un autre nom
qu'on peut associer au transhumanisme,
c'est à dire de Chardin et de Chardin.
Également utiliser ce terme transhumanisme
et effectivement le transhumanisme
ou l'intentionnalité.
C'est une réflexion sur sur,
sur le devenir de l'homme.
Effectivement.
Mais il est vrai que le transhumanisme
dont nous avons parlé cet après 12 h,
c'est vraiment
le transhumanisme technologique.
C'est notre rapport à la technique.
En fait, la technique devance devant nous
nos besoins, devant nos désirs.
Maintenant, vous allez sur Internet.
Vous le saviez pas
que deviez acheter des chaussures ?
L'algorithme vous dit qu'il
faut acheter des chaussures
parce que vous avez déjà navigué sur vous
avez été tracés, et cetera À quoi donc
la technologie va plus vite que nous ?
Et donc c'est notre rapport à la technique
qu'il faut vraiment questionner.
Et vous n'avez pas
la neutralité de la technologie ?
À savoir c'est l'utilisateur
soi disant le pauvre utilisateur
qui donne une orientation à la technique.
Je ne pense pas que soit il faut
absolument approfondir cette idée là
en pensant que non, parce qu'en fait
la technologie n'est pas neutre
à chaque fois
qu'on injecte de la technologie
dans un système, Dans une société,
l'homme est différent.
On a modifié avec nos téléphones
portables, on est complètement modifié
et donc la neutralité n'est pas.
Bien sûr, il y a des usages,
on peut faire attention, et cetera
Mais on nous a, on nous a plongé,
on nous a modifié
en quelqu'un qui a un téléphone portable
et quelqu'un qui en a pas.
C'est presque des humains différents.
Donc la technologie
poursuit ses propres fins et c'est pour ça
qu'on n'a parlé que de
que le transhumanisme technique, parce que
c'est notre transhumanisme
et ce qu'il faut bien.
Ce qu'il faut certainement,
c'est réfléchir à ce qu'est l'être humain
face à la technique qui avance,
qui avance, qui avance avant même
qu'on l'ait vu venir, avant
même qu'on l'ait vu venir.
C'est ça qu'il faut.
Il faut bien avoir une autre tendance,
aussi sacrée tendance à accepter,
accepter tout, tout,
tout ce qu'elle nous propose,
parce qu'elle nous propose toujours
un monde merveilleux,
plus ou moins électronique.
Mais c'est ce monde là. Donc c'est la.
C'est
effectivement notre rapport à la technique
et la technique n'est pas neutre.
Franchement,
toute toute entité, toute entité technique
dans un système modifie le système.
Ça, c'est très important
à bien bien saisir.
Voilà, on est loin de votre question
très compliquée.
On fait ce qu'on peut.
C'est une très bonne,
très bonne ouverture de réflexion
et une très bonne conclusion.
Merci à tous les deux
d'être venus ce soir.
C'est vrai que c'est un sujet très vaste.
On pourrait en parler pendant des heures,
mais je pense qu'on a
On a abordé pas mal de choses.
Je vous remercie aussi,
cher Public, d'avoir été présent,
d'avoir participé aussi aux échanges.
Merci à l'équipe de la technique.
Merci au café pour son accueil.
Merci à toutes et à tous.
Et on se retrouve le 7 décembre.
Oui, c'est bien ça
pour parler cette fois de la planète Mars.
Bonne soirée à très bientôt. Merci à tous,
puis.